hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play viscera
cleanup detail now I know how you guys
enjoy the robot vacuum simulator and
after that you just couldn't get enough
of the cleanup simulation so I thought
that I would treat you guys to a space
cleanup simulator I know you're probably
saying no it's true
it happened and it is the future and the
future is now
welcome to viscera cleanup detail now in
this game you play as a janitor on a
space station after a horrible alien
attack and I've actually never played it
before and there's some weird mop broom
but you can see after the remnants in
the horror then goes out the true work
begins as the janitors begin to click
yeah clean up the horrible mess if these
stupid soldiers leave behind
they don't understand Oh my mop is a
little uh little uh getting a little
blood filled here I think I need to dump
it out somewhere so where did I put my
mom up in here here put in there No is
that not good
one old disposal bins where do I put my
mop
oh my ere we go there we go got that
blood out of the way today I'm Shane
what these soldiers - they're so
careless they just leave their blood
lying around on the ground at least they
could do is die cleanly jeez this is
ruinous mess for the rest of it you see
simple soldiers they don't understand
the pain that the cleanup crew goes
through afterwards this I'm glad that
the game finally addresses this very
serious issue of understanding what
really goes on in the heart of the work
workforce is really all that matters in
these games and I am proud proud to
represent that in the world of gaming
today because it's not seen enough it's
just not seen enough gotta do more more
as we can can never do enough because
our work never ends I mean yeah the
aliens will come by and yeah
yeah they'll threaten to kill everything
we know and love but I stand by our
fellow men oh no my slaw cymatic it's
become full of scum damn it
see this is the challenges that we reach
every day I've got to find another mop
bucket because it's just not enough it's
never enough work work never changes man
this reminds me of other games that I've
played in the past have really
influenced me a long time ago I mean I
mean back in Deus Ex I mean really when
I was murdering all those other people
huh here we go
fresh bucket to use when I was murdering
all those other people in every other
horror game I've always thought you know
I've always regretted the mess that I've
left behind especially like you know
classic titles like Serious Sam
Duke Nukem yeah all those good games to
shame the mess it's always left behind
when you busy blowing up aliens sniff
not fair not fair
fine we some justice is done here all
right let's see getting some good stuff
work here done I'm sure I'll get a few
Awards when I go home to do this
starting to think that maybe there's all
there's a more more bigger mess later on
no no I don't know this just seems too
easy maybe I'm just too good at my job
get out of the way you stupid lungs god
damn at orzo just standing here how am I
supposed to clean this store bad
frigging tours oh gosh chappy you don't
understand and you Jimmy say you Jimmy
you're always playing pranks on me huge
joke's on you now I'm sorry I don't
often let my uh my work get to me like
that I've got to stay calm because I
really I really don't have I really
don't ask for the leisurely time that I
used to I'm older now oh do I have to uh
oh that what I have to do I have to put
these stupid body parts in the bins now
I have to do now oh where am I gonna
dump my mop this is crazy I can't
believe they expect me to work in an
environment like this oh god I don't
have nearly enough mop buckets they
don't budget enough
for the Janna ders man I did not go to
gana to school for eight freakin years
get my doctorate and Janna ring they
don't call me dr. Jana eat or for
nothing god what a waste
everything here is just ridiculous waste
I don't have anything can I get some
fresh water is that so much to ask
fine you know what you know what fine
just forget it forget I said anything
I'll just work with a dirty mop yeah
that's fantastic
what else do I have here okay I can use
my hands come here Jimmy
where are you well uh come on good shot
got ya okay got you Jimmy Jimmy come
here you've always been a problem now
you just have to keep a trash like
you've always thought you were man Jimmy
Lehman is mess everywhere [ __ ] I don't
care I guess he's dead now so that's
good
good for the whole station for what it
matters I guess he was okay kind of fun
at parties I guess whatever I'm just a
better janitor I should I shouldn't
complain I get paid well I knew my job
that's all that matters
am I supposed to do with this I'll be
doing with it give me toss you around a
bit oh wait a minute I know what I do
come here come here
scares me bucket you're my only friend
on this station I'll call you wall for
wall fort the wash bucket yeah they're
good say us wall Thorpe what the hell
and you gotta be joking me I gotta clean
up this mess again damn it I just
cleaned this wall Thorpe just clean it
never mind you know what forget it
forget it
it's a huge mess everywhere but you know
what that's just a story of my life even
the wash machine is messy again good
damn it forget it forget it give me a
fresh
[Applause]
okay you know what it's fine just forget
it it's fine finish my job here and I'm
gonna get this Nikes cleaned up well so
that people can go on and live their
lives in peace this God forsaken space
station and I do not care about is that
blood on there that better not be blood
it's all I have to say about that I'm
almost done
give me my damn thing and I'll go on my
merry way good unappreciated everywhere
I go whoo laughs bloody footprints in
here again hole glad he's dead
all right all right that looks good I
think we got just about everything here
no worries there's nothing to see okay I
think we're okay all right let me just
finish the last bit here and I'll be
fine and go on my merry way and then
I'll be able to do things Oh who's this
who is this
lift your intestines all over the place
how am I gonna clean up your individual
intestines when they're eviscerated all
over the floor really Jimmy how am I
supposed to do that just get in the
bucket really Jimmy you made my bucket
all dirty give me a new one
me anyone give me a new one surprise
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] a house
[Music]
give me your ball